what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a video that talks
about
how women feel attraction to men just
for being men before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos and if you guys have watched
three or more of my videos
and you have not hit the subscribe
button we have beef
beef okay
hit it takes like a second
please
okay
a girl sees herself okay
sexual people in the city all right
so you know how heterosexual guys they
see a girl differently than like a girl
sees herself okay
so
let's see let's say like
when guys go to a strip club versus like
when girls go to strip club when girls
go to certainly like
i'm talking about like female strippers
right they're like woo this is so much
fun oh my god we love you
and like you're amazing and like they're
giggling and they're having so much fun
right when guys go it's kind of more
serious
because guys are feeling the feminine
energy if you will a bit more strongly
than women are all right women are
thinking it's beautiful and maybe
they're getting a little bit of like
sexy from the girls
and they're
they're not really having the same
[Music]
reaction as guys are having the guys are
are hypnotized they're being put into
trance their hormones have gone like
insane
and their hormones have given them like
sex brain to the point where they're
just almost out of control
similarly
when i see a pair of boobs i'm just like
okay yeah a pair of boobs big whoop i
very nice or whatever
like when my boyfriend for example sees
one it's a totally different experience
i'm just like
i really don't get it um
but that's
kind of
man goggles you know what i'm saying
so
there's a very similar thing for women
seeing men
but i really believe that a lot of men
have no idea
that women
feel this way about guys
because
maybe not everyone does the same degree
like not all women feel this way to the
same degree
but
men have a
sexual energy and male energy
too that
my point is that
probably only women can see and feel and
reflect back to them
and that they themselves men cannot
really feel and see it in themselves
okay this is so true i've let her talk
for a little bit because i think this is
a really interesting intro but
men and women see each other completely
differently and we also see different
situations completely differently like
for example
when i had a job i was the only girl at
the office
and everyone would have been so helpful
like i loved that job everyone was
always helping me do things whatever and
one of my co-workers told me
that it was because i was a girl and he
did not get the same treatment
and if you asked any guy in the office
they would have told you the same thing
but that's the way like a man sees a
situation versus a girl who thinks oh
they're just being nice
now the reason i had to make this video
is because
some of my male friends like they get
really dejected and down because you
know they've they have not had much luck
with women
and maybe women have made fun of them in
the past and said like they're
unattractive in these certain ways
and they feel there is something
defective
about who they are that they are just
somehow fundamentally unattractive
to women
and i myself have rejected a lot of guys
you know back when i used to date
and
i rejected a lot of guys for different
reasons okay maybe this one was too shy
maybe this one was too quiet how ironic
right since i'm like the shyest and
quietest among
us all but
um maybe this guy he wasn't confident
enough
maybe this guy i didn't like his looks
really that that much maybe this guy
he wasn't like
you know
acting cool enough
like and that's the thing guys when you
get rejected you have no idea why the
girl is rejecting you
um for example
there are guys that i rejected them and
it had nothing to do with them
it was me
i was in a place in my life
where
i didn't realize it at the time but i
was too hung up on the last guy that i
never really gave any guys a chance
and
that didn't have anything to do with
them that didn't make them any less like
manly or attractive or whatever
it was me and a lot of times
you might get hung up on something and
think it's you and take it personally
but the less
or the more you can stop taking things
personally the better you're going to
have sorry the more you're going to have
success with women
because
oh my gosh women we the way our brains
are
we go by on our emotions those change
daily so or something
um
maybe this guy he was kind of too like
like begging and stuff and
maybe this guy he wasn't a good kisser
all of that all of those reasons to
reject a guy did not take away from
the way
how do i put this
all these reasons that i rejected guys
all right
i still felt each of these guys
attractive power ass guys it's like they
were doing annoying things and they were
doing things which i couldn't accept
that my high standards or whatever at
the time would not let me
accept them for
but i didn't think i didn't ever for one
second forget
that they were still
guys all right
and they still had and retained the
power
of a man the same power that i'm talking
about that you know a guy sees
when he sees you know a naked woman or a
really like sexy woman or something
all guys have that
and it's not visible to them but it is
visible to women and it comes and goes
it's the crazy thing because
as girls
i don't know how to describe it oh my
gosh i don't know how to describe it but
a guy does one thing and it either
builds or takes away from attraction so
you meet a guy and typically as women
you look for
whatever your five or ten things that
you look for are
um for me it's you know height right i'm
six foot so
that's a given um
you know similar values like
work ethic whatever it is
and
a lot of times we don't know
gosh i don't know how to describe it
like a lot of times
you guys will do something and i can't
even tell you
why it took away from attraction like
usually there's like the list of things
you look for so first you like look to
see if they meet whatever your minimum
qualifications are and then the next
step is okay do i think we'd get along
whatever am i attracted to this guy
enough to sleep with him stay in a
relationship with him whatever it is and
i i can't even tell you half the time
why a guy builds attraction and takes
away
like
it just happens
and i don't i don't know all right so
even when a girl is rejecting you for on
this reason
she still senses your
masculine power deep oh my gosh and if a
girl rejects you a lot of times if we
put you in the maybe category and we
tell you no but you're in the maybe
category in our head like
it's like attractive to us to feel
wanted almost
so
gosh this is so hard to describe so even
if you're in the maybe category and we
give you the no like sometimes we look
back and we rethink our decision
because
i don't know
this is not me telling you to keep dming
girls over and over and over and over
again don't do that but you guys
understand what i'm saying like
it's almost like
like a marble jar and you guys can
either put in marbles or take out
marbles and every interaction you have
with a girl either builds it or takes it
away
and
if you get above the threshold then it's
a yes from the girl and a lot of times
if you're close to like wherever that
line is
there are things you can do to build
attraction now what are they um i could
not tell you but
it's just
the way you're acting i can tell you
some things but for now acting or
whatever
isn't cool or maybe
you're not really unleashing and tapping
in to the power she knows you has and
she's just like i can't wait around all
day i can't deal with this you know what
i'm saying
but all guys have it even guys i've
rejected
i have still felt and seen their
attractive power
and i know that if they
almost like if they knew it was there
and they knew that i liked it and they
knew that i wanted it
and they
unleashed it or turned it on or suddenly
started to
bring that out more
it would be dangerous for me because
then i would be vulnerable because i
would be
able to be manipulated and i would be
kind of weak
if you know what i mean because it's so
attractive so it would put me at like a
disadvantage
so i will never like
i would never
point this out to a guy necessarily i'm
just like you know dude you're on your
own you figure it out because
i'm not going to make myself vulnerable
to tell you that i still find you
attractive and i'm not going to tell you
how
you could bring it out of yourself for
example um
i had this
male friend all right and i rejected him
um we were dating
one time he got really
angry at me in like a joking way all
right
and he really let like his
masculine
power that i always sensed under the
surface out
and i got really turned on but of course
i did not tell him that
okay but if he knew that and he knew
that you know he could bring that out
more he could use that against me
so
what is this masculine power um
it's
it's difficult to put you know words to
it but it's it's an energy
that all men have
that's extremely
powerful
it's raw it's
rough it's the power of
there's this book mode one okay
and it's kind of talking about this i
recommend you all read it
basically it said if every man took a
truth serum
and he said exactly what he thought
and he did exactly what he wanted
and he kind of
didn't give a [ __ ]
anymore
yeah guys this is why you should not
pander to women i know she i know where
she's going
when you guys have
this
i don't even know how to describe it but
it's a fake nice guy
persona
we see right through it
women are so much more perceptive than
men on social cues
so if you are saying something and it
doesn't match up to
who you are as a person and what you
believe based on your body language and
a lot of times we don't know why we
think this way
we
i can't like give you a real example as
to
why i think you're full of [ __ ] it's
just a feeling we have and it's natural
to us
so
it pandering to women isn't going to
help you and it isn't going to get you
anywhere um
and he said
brutal
brutal yeah brutal i guess raw honesty
about girls like you know instead of
just being like you're beautiful if what
he was really thinking was like oh my
god i would love to just like
throw you down on this couch and [ __ ]
you right now or whatever and it's like
kind of raunchy and
dirty but that was i'm blessing oh he
was honestly feeling that is attractive
all right if he's angry
and he acts angry that is attractive
it's
this power that men have that's just
like
maybe like if you're a guy watching this
you can understand it from the reverse
perspective like are there certain
things that women do when you're just
like
oh my god like i am at your mercy it's
the same for girls
with guys
certain things they do so my point in
this video is always know and always
remember that even if you're being
rejected by a girl that doesn't mean
that you're fundamentally unattractive
she knows you're a guy still okay and
all guys
have this
fundamental
attractiveness to women it's just that a
lot of times these guys are they don't
know how to bring it out and women
aren't going to help them because that
makes women vulnerable
and women don't always understand what
it is
that i don't know
made us less attracted to you we can't
always describe what it is it's a
feeling we get it so what do you think
of this video i hope you understand what
i'm saying and please i'd love to hear
any thoughts
okay guys what do you think do what are
things that make women fundamentally
attractive that we do that you might not
necessarily
think that we know we do
let me know in the comments don't forget
to subscribe and bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time